former president donald trump's
impeachment trial will not start until
next month if senate republican leader
mitch mcconnell gets his way
mcconnell says he doesn't want the
senate to rush into a trial
congressional correspondent nicole
killian is on capitol hill
nicole are democrats ready to start
right away
well anthony house speaker nancy pelosi
says she is
ready to hand over the article but
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
says he doesn't want a half big process
he argues that it is important for
both sides to have time to prepare and
that the former president
gets a fair trial some democrats are
willing to wait
but with conditions i would expect that
we'd be more receptive to this delay
if we are continuing to do the work of
the senate in confirming
the senior members of the cabinet across
all departments
senate democrats signaled they're open
to compromise as long as they're allowed
to continue
voting on president biden's cabinet
senator mcconnell proposed impeachment
managers deliver articles to the senate
on january 28th former president trump
would have to respond by february 4th
then he would get another week to file a
pre-trial brief
an aid to majority leader chuck schumer
says the idea
is under review leader mcconnell and i
are trying to come
up with a bipartisan agreement on how to
conduct the trial
but make no mistake about it there will
be a trial
it doesn't prove up an impeachable
offense the articles fail after mr
trump's
legal team from last year's impeachment
proceeding declined to represent him
again
allies of the former president say he
has hired south carolina lawyer butch
powers
president has a very good legal team a
great legal team
and we're going to fight like hell to
make sure that the second
impeachment of donald trump ends as
quickly as possible
either dismissed or with an overwhelming
vote for acquittal
today the senate holds a vote on defense
nominee lloyd austin
who could become the first black man to
lead the pentagon
senate leaders also want to confirm the
nominees for treasury and the state
department before the weekend
it is the secretary of state that is
fourth in line of secession
to the president of the united states
leaving the office vacant
is irresponsible a group of senate
democrats has filed an ethics complaint
against republican senators
josh hawley and ted cruz for objecting
to the results of the 2020
election a spokesperson for cruz accused
them of playing political games
while hawley called it a flagrant abuse
of the ethics process gail
thank you nicole there always seems to
be a lot of game playing in politics but
at the end of the day
you just want it to be fair really for
both sides whatever it's going to take
to make it fair and you also want to see
the senate bill to do walk and chew gum
at the same time right
i think you can proceed with the
impeachment while also taking votes on
important matters
most of all you want this administration
to get a chance to get settled in and
get going exactly it's called
multitasking people do it every day